[Musique]
parmi nous dans la rue nos entreprises
nos commerces nos hôpitaux se glissent
des citoyens qui veillent sur la France
et ses intérêts
par patriotisme ou désir d'être utile
après les attentats de 2015 ils ont
décidé d'endosser l'uniforme
ils sont 77000 formés aux disciplines
militaires ou apportant leur spécialité
depuis 2016 ils sont regroupés dans une
structure en appui des militaires
d’active ils forment toute une armée
qui sont-ils que font-ils comment les
rejoindre en suivant Philippe Vlad
Raphaël et Emma découvrez en mer en
montagne ou dans les airs entre vissy
ville et activité militaires les
multiples facettes des réservistes de la
garde nationale
[Musique]
aujourd'hui j'encadre les Bac Pro ce
sont des jeunes qui ont signé un
partenariat avec la Marine nationale qui
sont en première professionnelle et en
terminale professionnelle avec des
spécialités axées sur la mécanique et
l'électricité ou les systèmes
informatiques bonjour c'est un plaisir
de faire découvrir la Marine nationale à
ces jeunes là
[Musique]
un côté un petit peu bon père de famille
on est là pour les aider dans leur
premier pas au sein de la Marine
nationale contrôle si les stagiaires ils
sont ils font bien leur poste de
propreté le poste de propreté dans la
marine c'est une institution et puis
après il y a tout un côté Vimaire donc
on leur apprend un petit peu à marcher
au pas allez bougez-vous les gars cette
colonne là mettez derrière il faut trois
colonnes 1 2 3 parfait
17 ans dans la Marine nationale à bord
des sous-marins nucléaire d'attaque et
SNA aussi une partie dans les écoles de
la marine ici
c'est vrai que moi dès que j'ai
l'occasion ben je vais dire aux jeunes
de pas hésiter à aller au sous-marin
parce que c'est vraiment une école déjà
de la vie c'est vraiment un milieu qui
seront jamais l'occasion de découvrir
ailleurs et que c'est une chance que la
Marine nationale offre de pouvoir aller
prendre une douche 300 mètres sous l'eau
avec de l'eau chaude chauffée par un
réacteur nucléaire
quand j'ai pris ma retraite en 2012 on
m'a demandé si j'étais volontaire pour
faire des réserves j'ai plutôt choisi de
venir ici au PEM au pôle ecole
Méditerranée qui me permet de venir en
saison morte au tonnes et printemps en
fait en tant que réserviste on a les
mêmes responsabilités moi j'ai la même
tenue que quand j'étais destructeur ici
open on est traité exactement pareil
donc là on va aller voir le dicmud qui
lui aussi est au bassin les valeurs pour
moi c'est l'esprit d'équipage l'esprit
qu'on est ensemble qu'on va y arriver
qu'on attend le dernier qu'on se met à
son niveau qu'on essaye de le tirer en
avant voilà c'est un peu des valeurs
qu'on essaye de leur apprendre et de se
dire que
qu'on a bien fait de choisir cette voie
là et qu'on va se régaler on est là pour
leur donner confiance en eux et puis
leur faire partager leur faire voir
physiquement avec la Marine nationale
c'est un beau moyen de réussite dans la
vie
on part du quai elle arrive là elle
vient ici sur le rouleau et elle vient
ici sur la poupée passion les deux c'est
vraiment c'est de la patience je suis
passionné de montagne et j'ai réussi à
me reconvertir la dent et puis depuis
tout petit j'ai toujours été attiré par
la mer le voyage et maintenant c'est une
passion de transmettre cette envie aux
jeunes de naviguer de découvrir le monde
et d'apprendre d'apprendre des choses
tant au point de vue technologique qu'au
point de vue humain la seule corde que
vous avez à bord
il y a aucune cor
de à bord ou des haussières
donc là on remonte dans le fourgon on
rentre au Pen arrivé au pain vous allez
à l'amphi Foch et quant à moi fin de
mission je vous quitte aussi pour
remonter chez moi dans d'évoluy et
attaquer la saison 6
dès lundi allez on y va
[Musique]
la gare de nationale a été créée pour
contribuer à la protection de notre pays
elle regroupe les réservistes
opérationnels de 10 composantes des
ministères des armées et de l'intérieur
ces volontaires appuient les forces de
l'ordre renforcent les militaires de
l'opération sentinelle surveille
l'espace aérien ou le littoral participe
au plan d'urgence ou apportent leur
expertise
le cas de Vlad arrivé de Roumanie à 22
ans il offre ses compétences médicales
au service de santé des armées une façon
d'exprimer sa reconnaissance à la France
j'aime la France j'aime la médecine je
trouve que partir à l'armée m'ouvre la
possibilité de vivre la médecine d'une
manière différente et plus complète plus
complémentaire je vais prendre mon
uniforme je vais embarquer au bord du
Monge pour une mission de médecine
embarquée l'armée c'est une façon pour
un individu
d'exprimer son appartenance à la
citoyenneté
je partage mon temps entre la gestion de
mon cabinet libéral et les activités de
réserve opérationnelles le plus souvent
pour la marine mais aussi au profit de
l'armée de terre ou de la gendarmerie
installez-vous les attentes pour cette
mission c'est de faire ce petit bilan et
ensuite si un cas se produit d'être en
mesure de me poser et de me dire à moi
comme mon nom s'il y a des besoins
d'évacuation des besoins de prise en
charge merci d'assurer ce type de
mission qui permet un commandant de
dormir sur ces deux oreilles leur rôle
d'un médecin abort d'un bateau c'est
d'assurer le soutien santé pour le
membre de l'équipage et cela passe par
la gestion des situations
urgentes par les pathologies bénignes du
quotidien mais aussi et surtout par la
prévention et participer du point de vue
médical aux décisions du commandement
bonjour le rôle du médecin projetait un
OPEX n'est pas forcément
gérer des afflux massifs de blessés
au large avec un infirmière anesthésiste
représente une
réussite parce que du fait
d'impossibilité d'évacuation l'évolution
peut-être rapidement défavorable
je fais des modules de médecine
embarqués j'ai fait des cours de
chirurgie en mission extérieure j'ai
fait des formations même militaires rien
ne laisse transparaître le fait que je
viens du monde civil de la réserve en
revanche mes compétences à partir du
moment où j'ai c'est uniforme se doivent
de répondre aux attentes des de
l'équipage
de connaissance vous avez un loup le
service de santé des armées apporte
ainsi son soutien médical partout les
armées sont déployés vous êtes un petit
peu sonné
un petit traumatisme peut devenir
rapidement sérieux parce que les
possibilités de prise en charge sont
limitées par rapport à la médecine qu'on
connaît à terre lorsque je commence mes
activités de réserve
je sais que je vais appartenir à une
famille je trouve des gens qui partagent
des valeurs que je pense j'ai pu
cultiver être droit être correct la
rigueur le respect une certaine exigence
envers soi-même il y a pas de signe de
gravité moi je vous propose qu'on garde
l'immobilisation du genou et du poignet
et très uniforme c'est appartenir à
autre chose je me présente une
institution quand on vient du monde
civil et encore plus du monde libéral on
cherche quelque chose que l'on n'a pas
au quotidien de notre existence on ne
peut pas exclure une appendicite mais on
se tient prêt pour le chaos l'armée et
la Marine en particulier me font vibrer
parce que j'ai l'impression que les
valeurs que je porte sont celles des
gens qui s'y trouvent
[Musique]
quittant la mer pour la montagne nous
retrouvons Philippe notre marin alors
que la saison de ski bat son plein
bonjour bienvenue dans le dévolu
ça change un peu de décor on a perdu en
température en augmentant en altitude
mais bienvenue et on va passer une bonne
journée ensemble il va falloir
s'habiller
et rejoindre la station je prends ma
bias sac de bouffe et on est parti
les clés
de la Ferrari
alors là on va la station de La Joue du
Loup le métier de pisteur secouriste
c'est
sécurisé le domaine skiable
on va les entretenir
et puis assurer les secours
là tu vois il y a le cabinet médical
derrière donc on arrive ici en barquette
on sort le brancard on les met sur le
brancard on les amène le public à Toulon
les jeunes on est vraiment là pour eux
c'est vraiment une relation de confiance
qu'on essaye d'avoir avec eux et puis
ici on essaie de aussi chouchouter nos
clients évidemment puisqu'il faut qu'ils
aient une bonne image de la station
c'est vrai que de ce côté là c'est un
petit peu la même chose s'occuper des
des autres
voilà donc ça c'est le poste de secours
voilà et là je vais partir au gris
les pistes qui restent à ouvrir côté
joue quand j'ai signé pour l'active
c'était un aspect que je pouvais pas
négliger le fait d'aller au combat
d'ailleurs j'ai fait le Kosovo et puis
après l'Afghanistan et là si aujourd'hui
il fallait aller défendre la France et
mon pays au sein de la Marine nationale
bah ouais j'irai
cette part d'encadrement elle est tout à
fait adaptée aux gens qui ont déjà
quitté la Marine qui ont une expérience
courte du temps disponible à consacrer
aux jeunes pour délester la marine il
est là
je m'en occupe on est vraiment soudé
quoi on est une équipe dans l'équipe je
trouve que j'ai retrouvé un petit peu
cet esprit d'équipage où on s'entend
tous super bien et où on est aussi
soumis aux éléments puisque bon ben en
mer on se doute bien que c'est pas
toujours le calme plat et ben en
montagne c'est pareil c'est pas toujours
le soleil et la belle neige pour les
pisteurs c'est aussi froid le mauvais
temps et puis on prend les choses du bon
côté et on s'en sort toujours on y
arrive toujours c'est une belle occasion
la réserve et puis aussi un petit apport
financier moi qui suis saisonnier ben je
crache pas dessus tu gagnes sur tous les
plans
je me vois mal faire de l'encadrement
pendant toute ma réserve j'aimerais
changer et puis faire si c'est possible
pourquoi pas de l'opérationnel
le dernier étape de la journée fermeture
des pistes on va attendre les derniers
clients descends avec eux jusqu'en bas
de la station et après c'est le retour à
la maison
à quelques encablures de la station
Superdévoluy se trouve le quatrième
chasseur de Gap sa double spécialité
montagne et blindée en fait l'un des
régiments de France les plus projetés
la réserve lui est donc une ressource
indispensable
au Liban et en banc de silos aérienne
c'est intéressant de pouvoir conduire
cette rue de programmation afin de voir
dans quelle mesure le cinquième escadron
peut appuyer les escadrons dans
différentes missions le 4ème Régiment de
chasseur un rythme d'activité qui est
particulièrement dense on a la chance
d'avoir une réserve qui est extrêmement
volontariste pour prendre le relais dans
des périodes clés capitaine je suis
passé pendant les fêtes de fin d'année
au régiment et dans une bonne partie de
la garde qui était armée par le
cinquième escadron et je viens de
féliciter pour cet engage gros qui était
massif donc bravo pour pour le travail
réalisé ton personnel pour ce travail la
réserve est représente 20% des effectifs
quasiment du régime
c'est un renfort qui est indispensable
pour les opérations et les missions
qu'on mène que ce soit sur le territoire
national au quartier ou en opération
extérieure on a la chance de pouvoir
compter sur un personnel qui est formé à
la fois montagne et à la fois en blindé
et je pense que c'est vraiment cette ces
deux spécificités qui passionnent en
fait les jeunes réservistes vous êtes au
contact de l'élite
c'était notre volonté avec le capitaine
que vous ayez une instruction avec les
GCM du régiment une instruction de haut
niveau et votre objectif premier et
votre mission c'est vous donner plus
qu'a fond donc on est aujourd'hui ici
rassemblée pour vous dispenser une
instruction sur les actes élémentaires
du combattant et après avoir évalué
votre niveau on verra qu'est-ce qu'il
est possible de faire j'ai fait le choix
de m'engager au sein de la garde
nationale pour devenir reserviste pour
deux raisons de novembre 2019 j'ai
appris la mort d'un ami le brigadier
Ronan pointeau lors d'une opération
au Mali j'ai pris conscience de ce qui
était vraiment l'esprit de corps au sein
de leur mieux qu'est-ce qui était la
solidarité le dépassement de soi et
notamment ce qui peut amener aussi au
sacrifice et il y a un second événement
tout aussi douloureux pour beaucoup de
personnes qui étaient la période de la
crise sanitaire et moi je me suis
retrouvé en fait à la maison en
télétravail loin de la Tour Eiffel il me
manquait ce contact avec les autres
personnes qui pourraient avoir besoin
d'aide tout se fait en sécurité les
appuis sont présents c'est bien
donc moi j'ai trois critères communiqués
bouger tirer j'ai l'opportunité de
d'avoir davantage de responsabilité
petit à petit j'ai commencé en tant que
première classe je viens de passer le
camée qui me permettra dans quelques
mois je l'espère de devenir brigadier et
donc d'être chef d'équipe pour pouvoir
encadrer deux PACS à l'avenir
et moi je reste face midi comme ça là il
y a une porte qui va permettre aux
autres de pouvoir traverser c'est une
expérience incroyable très enrichissante
humainement nous apprenons énormément on
a la chance d'utiliser différentes armes
que ce soit le FAMAS le HK le glock
voire même la MAC 58 ce qui est pas
commun au sein de toute les réserves en
France mais ce qui me plaît le plus au
sein de la réserve déjà c'est l'esprit
cordé un certain engagement on a envie
de se dépasser soi-même et de se rendre
utile pour le collectif et une volonté
d'exercer dans un milieu fantastique
quel est la montagne
à l'entraînement qu'on vient de faire
avec les GCM c'était très intéressant
voire même un honneur de pouvoir les
côtoyer et d'avoir leurs conseils mes
camarades ont le même avis sur le sujet
c'est vraiment quelque chose de super on
a ouvert leurs petites boîtes à outils
et on leur a mis quelques clés pour
améliorer les manœuvres la fluidité et
leur restriction ça me tient quand même
à cœur parce que j'ai réalisé un an de
réserve avant de m'engager dans l'A il y
a maintenant 10 ans je trouve que c'est
important qu'ils aient un bon pli
d'entrée de jeu et comment plus ils sont
volontaires font profiter faut se lancer
ne pas avoir peur et allez-y
actuellement la réserve du quatrième
chasseur à travers son cinquième
escadron et complètement opérationnel la
preuve en est c'est que on a réussi à
monter en puissance deux pelotons de
reconnaissance sur VBL et c'est dans ces
dans ces pelons là qu'on a pu extraire
des personnels pour renforcer les
escades actives en l'occurrence cette
année on m'a envoyé plusieurs personnels
au Mali sur certains postes chef de
patrouille et pilote VBL en renfort du
deuxième escadron je suis parti au Niger
à Niamey et notre zone d'action c'était
le frontière Malo nigérienne moi je suis
parti en tant que adjoint chef de
patrouille au Mali alors la base a lancé
de Gossi c'était pour contrer les
actions les actions terroristes sur
place ça c'est très très bien passé très
bien intégré donc on était vraiment
considérés comme un soldat professionnel
en 2021 un peu plus de 1000 jours ont
été réalisés par les réservistes du
régiment sur le territoire associatel
à mettre ta sur prépare à la haute
intensité la réserve aura tout son rôle
pour éventuellement capacité de
régénération l'émission peuvent être
multiples pour la réserve et surtout
dans ce contexte assez incertain et avec
risque d'affrontement majeur dans le
futur ils sont ainsi 77000
issus de la société civile ou ancien
d'active à être aujourd'hui engagé
la proportion de femmes est un peu
supérieure à celle de l'active puisqu'on
en compte 20%
[Musique]
ils appartiennent pour moitié aux armées
pour moitié aux forces de l'ordre
près de la moitié de ses réservistes
exerce un travail en parallèle
leur engagement est parfois soutenu par
leur entreprise
le groupe Bouygues a signé en 2018 une
convention avec la garde nationale pour
faciliter les missions de ces salariés
réservistes
[Musique]
parmi eux Élise
je suis sous-officier de réserve au sein
du 24e régiment d'infanterie ça fait
depuis 2017 que je me suis engagée et je
me suis engagée en tant que militaire
durant on y amené du coup à remplacer à
soutenir en fait les militaires d'actifs
c'est aussi principalement des missions
opérationnelles de type sentinelle
je suis ingénieur travaux donc je
travaille sur chantier avec les équipes
pour mener à bien des opérations de
construction entre la vie de chantier et
la vie militaire il y a énormément de
points communs le sens de la rigueur la
réactivité il faut toujours faire preuve
il y a des valeurs de cohésion aussi
qu'on retrouve surtout avec les équipes
c'est vraiment quelque chose que qu'on
développe au fur et à mesure du temps
que ce soit sur le chantier et alarmant
on est là pour pour dissuader avant tout
toutes mes masques et vous avez fait
combien de jours l'année dernière de
période de réserve
70 jours
c'est énorme Martin Bouygues a signé
avec la ministre des Armées fut une
convention de soutien à la réserve
opérationnelle avec la gare de nationale
qui vise surtout encourager faciliter
fluidifier l'engagement de nos
collaborateurs dans leur période de
réserviste opérationnel c'est une
richesse d'abord d'avoir des
collaborateurs qui s'engagent au service
de leur pays avec un état d'esprit
excellent une volonté de se mettre au
service une volonté de transmettre et ça
ce sont des valeurs qui nous paraissent
vraiment primordial
actuellement plus de 850 employeurs
encouragent ainsi l'engagement de leur
personnel
Rafael rentrait de son entraînement avec
les commandos montagne retrouve son
directeur à la société d'exploitation de
la Tour Eiffel il a bénéficié de jours
offerts par son entreprise
dans notre chalet montagne à
Saint-Étienne-en-Dévoluy dans le massif
du dévolu pour passer un stade supérieur
pour devenir brigadier
un jour un réserviste à la Tour Eiffel
qui est venue me voir en me disant voilà
qu'à côté de ses activités il avait une
activité de gendarmes et du coup j'ai
dit qu'il fallait absolument essayer de
développer slide la Tour Eiffel
concrètement on a mis en place une
convention avec la garde nationale qui
permet de faciliter le travail de mes
salariés qui veulent devenir réservistes
ce personnel qui est engagé c'est un
personnel qui est positif c'est un
personnel qui a le sens du de l'esprit
collectif quel sens de l'intérêt général
il faut absolument essayer de promouvoir
ce type de d'engagement au service des
concitoyens depuis quelques mois une
convention a été signée entre la garde
nationale la société d'exploitation de
la Tour Eiffel qui permet à ses salariés
réserviste de bénéficier de 20 jours de
disponibilité avec un maintien du
salaire et la possibilité d'avoir
seulement 15 jours de prévenance donc il
facilite notre disponibilité justement
auprès de notre employeur
au sein de la société d'exploitation de
la Tour Eiffel j'exerce le métier de
juriste spécialisé dans la commande
publique et les marchés publics
notamment tandis que à la réserve
aujourd'hui je suis première classe donc
mon niveau de responsabilité est assez
faible
la réserve m'a apporté davantage de
confiance en moi une certaine assurance
un peu plus d'aplomb au quotidien
notamment dans mon métier car je suis
souvent confronté à des réunions où je
me retrouve avec le plus jeune donc il
faut savoir tenir bon et assurer sa
position en restant en ferme
on engagement au sein de la réserve a
été très bien perçu au sein de la 7 mes
collègues ont été mes premiers soutiens
ils sont assez admiratifs et très
bienveillants très curieux aussi de
savoir ce que je fais quand je pars lors
d'exercices ou une mission ça va ça va
et toi bon je retrouve Guillaume un
autre réservice de la société
d'exploitation de la Tour Eiffel on va
aller discuter de la mission de ce
week-end sur la Tour Eiffel je suis
électricien donc ça va être pour tout ce
qui va toucher du 12 Volts au 20000 V
j'avais envie de me rendre utile de de
m'engager pour mon prochain et je me
suis dit que la gendarmerie c'était une
belle idée des belles valeurs que je
partage on va aller aider
insister les gendarmes d'actifs et donc
ça a été même mission qu'on soit appelé
pour un cambriolage qu'on soit appelé
pouvoir sécuriser des zones encadrer des
événements que ça soit fin de la
prévention on est là pour les aider dans
leur quotidien tous les jours certains
comme Raphaël et Guillaume apprennent un
nouveau métier d'autres comme Vlad et
Emma apportent leur spécialité
communicantes dans le civil et mal est
aussi au profit de l'Armée de l'Air et
de l'Espace
une bonne dizaine d'années j'étais
journaliste reportée à l'image
réalisatrice aussi de vidéos pour des
marques je connaissais pas spécialement
la réserve en France et finalement c'est
en rentrant des réservistes aux
États-Unis des réservistes chez les
Marines ce que j'ai découvert ce que
c'était réellement je suis rentrée de
mon voyage et je suis tout de suite
allée dans un CIRFA pour dire voilà mon
CV ma lettre de motive je vais être
réserviste on est parti de bon matin à
7h pour aller sur la base aérienne 123
Orléans Brissy et on va aller à la
découverte de l'escadron Touraine
[Musique]
bonjour
bienvenue au sein du Touraine vous avez
passé une petite journée en notre
compagnie donc ça vous permettra de voir
un petit peu nos missions l'emploi de
nos réservistes à l'escadron et puis
pouvoir participer à un vol cet
après-midi la notion de servir mon pays
je pense que c'est vraiment la valeur
commune à tous les militaires d'active
ou de réserve et la deuxième chose en
fait qui m'a attiré dans l'armée c'était
de faire mon métier autrement et donc
d'avoir un rapport aux gens différents
est-ce que vous êtes amené à travailler
des réservistes autours
[Musique]
bien le relais en tant que officier
communication réserve je permet de faire
rayonner la réserve donc donner plus de
visibilité je trouve que c'est c'est un
grand service à rendre aux armées à
réservistes il a il a sa vie dans le
civil cette famille son travail ses
activités et c'est quelqu'un qui a une
autre démarche de faire quelque chose en
plus il se quelque chose en plus bah ça
impose de se lever tôt le matin de faire
du sport de repasser ses chemises en
commun c'est un engagement c'est le
désir
d'apporter quelque chose en plus à son
quotidien et j'ai toujours une base
aérienne c'est comme une ville donc on a
des cuisiniers on a des RH on a des
secrétaires on a des commandos mais il y
a absolument de tout et l'armée de l'air
c'est pas juste des pilotes et des
parachutistes comme on disait il y a
quelques temps il fait toute une armée
pour faire voler nos avions et c'est
vrai donc pour la réserve ça s'applique
aussi
[Musique]
donc le fait de pouvoir employer ces
réservistes ça nous permet et d'offrir
qu'un nombre de missions réalisables au
profit des forces armées plus important
mais également de diminuer la pression
opérationnelle sur des tâches en vol
mais également sur des tâches au sol de
fonctionnement au quotidien de
l'escadron si on veut
deborer qui sont les centres
d'information et de recrutement des
forces armées il y en a un peu partout
dans toutes les grandes villes de France
tout ce qui est salon ou que ce soit les
salons de l'étudiant salon du Bourget la
fabrique défense ou généralement la
garde nationale à un stand où les armées
ont leurs propres stands aussi et là il
y a toujours des réservistes qui sont
dans le coin qui peuvent répondre à vos
questions on a le site de la garde
nationale donc on peut trouver
facilement les informations pour se
renseigner dans un premier temps sur
devenir resariste et puis une fois qu'on
est sur qu'on veut s'engager c'est là
qu'on va sur le site qu'on appelle rock
à savoir réserver ce point en
défense.gouv.fr et voilà tout de suite
sur la page d'accueil vous avez je
souhaite devenir réserviste il suffit de
créer un compte et à partir de là on a
la carte de France qui s'affiche avec
tous les endroits où les armées sont
implantés en tant que femme j'ai
vraiment eu aucune appréhension à
intégrer l'armée parce que mon est quand
même en 2022 le monde rouge le monde a
aussi beaucoup bougé avant et
honnêtement j'ai jamais jamais eu de
problème on sent pas moins militaire que
les autres et puis moi je vois surtout
ça chez les toutes jeunes réservistes là
elles ont une niaque à son elles sont
vraiment prêtes à tout arracher et plus
que ma génération à moi je trouve donc
les garçons donc il y a bien se tenir
[Musique]